today's new member of the day is cody
mukesh 'ok cody thank you so much for
being a david pakman show member we only
exist because our viewers support us
through membership please sign up at
david pakman.com slash membership louis
i don't know about you but i think we
should take some calls the number is 6 1
7 8 30 for 750 name in town who is
joining us first day Tom Hammond done
where you calling from from cakes
Oklahoma and what what can we do for you
today well I was wondering um I'd listen
uh and Chicago um part of my life and
the rest in Oklahoma I was said I've
witnessed a great deal of violence in my
life and I'm wondering um how much
actual violence have you witnessed uh
either as a an adult or a child and I
would like to ask Lewis the same
question and uh sure the responses very
little for me uh I mean uh really not
that but when we're talking about in
person violence really very little I
mean I would I fortunately did not grow
up in a violent household and really
other than just basically street fights
and school fights and fights on the
streets of Austin Texas when I went to
visit Louis when he was living there for
example uh I I really have not witnessed
a lot of violence personally Louis what
about you uh my answer would be similar
I guess mostly just your usual
hand-to-hand hand-to-hand fights uh
ranging in in um I don't know I
intensity I guess you could say and I
don't believe I've seen incidents with
with weapons involved yeah but uh I have
seen certainly countless
bloodied faces an unconscious people
yeah yeah I'd the to fight I've been in
go back to I believe fourth and sixth
grade fourth grade involved someone
throwing a football at my face point
blank and then me kicking the person and
then in sixth grade there was like
basically a simultaneous punch in the
jaw with very big winter gloves on since
I grew up in Massachusetts so at recess
you had to wear thick winter gloves it
was basically wearing a boxing glove and
I punched another kid simultaneously he
punched me and then that was basically
it so I don't know I don't know that
that's going to be too interesting to
you done I what I was hoping to hear
something along those lines
unfortunately I experienced a great deal
of violence in my life and I was
wondering the correlation uh the caller
that was saying the violence of video
games would be uh detrimental to uh the
advancement of your childhood as opposed
to actual violence and I'll stick that
off the year yeah that a very
interesting call yet right I mean
interesting Lee enough Lewis very into
violent video games not really involved
or experiencing real-world violence and
I'm sure the case could be made that
being around real-world violence will
much more significantly influence one uh
then then video game violence I I think
as a general principle that's that's
probably true